and I thought you might get here and
right now I am Yosh and I am delighted
to introduce a nico to the all right
good morning your audio thanks for
coming so early and so it's great it's a
great honor to be here so I'm really
happy to take this industry perspective
and tell you a little about how some of
them matching markets or match in
general that we've been discussing in
the last few days apply to things we do
at Facebook and things that others
company too so what I gonna do today
instead of like focusing one paper and
going deep in that paper is to give you
an overview of different things we do at
Facebook to try to run products and
inform these products from decisions
that have to do with matching market how
we can scale this so we can do this you
know with big markets with many many
items on both sides of the market and
also how to run this accurately and what
I'm gonna be presenting today are
basically material was taken from
different papers different projects and
slides were also taken from different
people thanks to many of them many of
them are coffers of mine or people who
work with me in different projects all
right so matching markets so matching
market basically appears in many many
places at Facebook things even like feed
if you look at Facebook feed or
Instagram feed you can think of that as
a matching market in the cell or a
matching problem in the sense that you
have to map post to users in some way
and then show those post to those users
so what you're doing is you're trying to
match two sides of the market and when
you look at these products up here and
I'm gonna giving you many examples
throughout the talk basically there are
different things you have to consider
for the first one I mentioned scale so
we need to solve these problems and
these problems are super large we have
millions or billions of items on one of
the sides of the market and in solve
them usually very fast if you have to
render a feed you have a few
milliseconds to do that operation before
you have you have to transmit the
webpage to the user
who's gonna be looking at that as you
start modeling the other thing is also
you need to be accurate so so many of
these problems will rely on the data
that destroy the problem the data may be
the notes on the two sides of the market
the edges that connect the nodes or even
the weights that will be on the edges
and usually people use machine learning
to learn some of those weights and the
question is how to do this properly so
the outcome of these you know the of the
solutions of these problems make some
sense to then inform what you're gonna
be doing in that context like you have
to deal with many side constraints like
one of them would be that you want the
solution to be fair or equitable in some
respect I'll give a few examples later
or other side constraints for example
you may not want to be say all post like
one after the other to be of same type
because you may want some diversity in
what you get also real life you have to
deal with the problem being stochastic
or online you have all the information
beforehand so you have to forecast
what's going to happen and depending on
the nature of the problem you may take
that as an online problem or stochastic
problem of different kinds and in the
context of markets there are these two
sides aspects that may be the two sides
need to grow out different stays you
want to balance the sides and there are
things that you want to do there so this
type of matching markets have been look
at from different perspectives so one of
them would be to look at the flow
problem and that's one I've used a lot
in the past for solving this type of
thing so you can associate the super so
super nerd is sorry super source and
super sink and so the flow problem there
but actually matching markets can can be
a Hardeen looked from many different
perspectives so flow never on graphs you
can look at this as sorting and ranking
type of algorithm some people in machine
learning have been looking at this type
of thing in which you not only look at
the assignment but when you look at a
feed problem like the one I mentioned
earlier you wanna see like in what order
we want to display all these items you
can also look at this as a recommender
systems in which maybe you know that a
given user look at posts of a given kind
already and you want to recommend the
next type of post that the user may like
so in practice
see like in a big company like Facebook
there are many groups of specialize in
different things and when you take any
of these problems and you talk to
engineers that are engineers and product
managers designing a product you need to
have all these views and depending the
at the end of the day what groups end up
collaborating in a project like you have
all the input from people that are going
to be looking at a problem from any of
those perspectives or all of those
perspectives at the same time and you
have to make some sense out of that to
try to give a recommendation of what to
implement to you know to make some sense
out of a problem and this goes our
different scales or different scopes so
at some point for example you want to
design the product and you have to you
want to make decisions about how the
product is gonna behave under different
conditions so that's one aspect the
other aspect is that after the product
is design you may use some of these
ideas to then guide the operations of
the product so for example solve a
problem and based on the solution of the
problem maybe run the field or or weaken
and something so all these all these
perspectives are present in everyday
life in a company like Facebook so the
goal basically is what I was saying so
we have a very complex system a stably
dynamic where users may come in go out
churn and things are happening all the
time
what you like to do is you like to
capture the essence of those in a very
simple model and like I like that can be
solved if you cannot solve it then it's
not very useful to you so you need to be
able to solve it and then that solution
you're already using to either like take
the strategic view and help you design
the product or take the operations view
and help you guide the operations of the
product and as I said earlier the
blockers are you need to be able to
solve it first and then the solution is
to make some sense so you need to be
able to calibrate it so you can forecast
really what would happen if you were to
actually implement what the model is
capturing so how to do all that is is
release some of the challenges that we
run into every day so for this talk and
initially I wanna take this the
protective of matchings from a market
place design
so like in a market mechanism but I want
to do that in a way that you know you
look the market from behind so for
example if you look at the ad auction in
which you know every time a user comes
up we'll run the auction to decide how
much to charge and what what ad to show
to whom instead of looking at that
auction production will not take it at a
distance and then look at this market as
a market so like as a competitive
equilibrium market and then from there
try to understand what are the prices
and what gets assigned to who so that
that's the perspective I'm going to take
for this table for now so if you look at
market equilibria basically what you get
as input is an instance of a matching
market or of the matching you get buyers
and you get items people you have budget
for the buyers and supply is finite
supplies for the items you have
preferences for the buyers of what items
they prefer for the items they have
prices and what you want is you want the
market to clear so basically what you
want is you want to set prices such that
supply quality man and you want to set a
location so the buyers are happy with
the items they got and all this cutting
studied like very much and there are
algorithms and there are many properties
are known for this so one view we can
take is for for this type of matching
markets we can solve using this concept
of market equilibria and then we get
automatically many of the properties
that we know that these these objects
have so the view is I'm gonna take this
as the Cee I type of market equilibria
and so if you want to saw one of this
matching market we can ask everybody
what their preferences are we can give
people some fake money or real money
depending on situation and determine
situation also you can you can come up
with a goal and utility function for the
goods and so sorry for the buyers in
this case so can be quasi linear will be
the utility of the goods plus the money
they are left with if money has no value
then it shows the utility get
from there good then you solve the
problem and you take that output to then
guide either your product or your
algorithm to be able to do what you need
to do this has been using in many cases
I have some examples here a for example
in Business School so for MBA programs
students are giving these fake money and
they can bid for courses and we can use
this type of arguments to the assign
students to courses
so as I was saying earlier so the hope
is that we can use these type of objects
to then guide the operations and
understand what we want to do in these
type of settings one of the one of the
big things that happen in practice is
that when you have a complex product you
may have the product be interacting with
many other products in company and one
of the issues that arise is that you
have trade off between different metrics
that different parts of the company may
be pushing for and what's not clear in
practice is what these trade offs are
and is hard to quantify in practice so
one of the goals will be to prove these
models to be able to understand these
trade offs and see like under different
operating parameters or different
proposed mechanisms like what happens
between the metrics so if you can solve
these models for you know four different
realizations or different variations of
what's going to happen then you can
quantify precisely how these metrics are
going to look like under different
operating points and that's one of the
goals of being able to model things in
practice you cannot you can also answer
what if questions contractile questions
what if we subsidize one side of the
market what would happen or what if we
change the way that we connect like the
left side to the right side so we have a
more dense graph what would happen with
it so through these type of approaches
we can answer these questions we can
also answer another important questions
which is one that happened in practice
that engineers go and implement an
approach usually they implement a greedy
approach which is the easiest to you
know to code and and then to roll out so
now I have a greedy approach and people
ask you well how good are we so if you
come out a marvel of this kind then you
can also solve for optimality and then
look at the benchmark of how well you're
doing compared to the best you could do
at least if we believe that model that
the mode will give you something
concrete so in some cases you are not
able to solve the model in a time that
you have to really make the assignments
but you can do this offline at least you
can do it to compare and see how far you
are from optimal in those cases
so for today what I decided to focus on
are on two sides one is about scale as I
said so how to be how one can solve
problems that are large in the setting
of competitive equilibrium and the
second part is about Bayesian
optimization on how to learn how to
learn a model so we can be accurate so
here are like some papers that refer to
that that you know I come I'll point
some of the main results there in the
talk but those are references so you can
look at them later on so let me start
with an example so if you look at the
ads market at Facebook so the way this
works is that we have advertisers here
that decide who to target for ads so for
example these jewelry firm we decide to
target all females and this retailer
will target everybody and this a fashion
firm will target young adults so now the
way this works is when a user shows up
for example this woman who is 24 years
old shows up we look at all the ads that
target here and they will run the
auction so all these advertisers will
send me to the system a budget and a bid
and then using those bids we run the
auction and whoever wins gets to show
the other to do that particular user now
as I said earlier like if you model this
you have to model like auction
production what's gonna happen and that
may be complicated so one way to look at
that and this is what we've done like in
these papers like a first and second
price pacing papers and that we work on
for last couple of years what we do is
we look at this from the distance and
try to solve this system as a community
equilibrium so if you look at this from
a company boolean perspective then what
you have is you get prices for all the
all the users and then the assignment is
gonna happen automatically from that
competitive equilibrium and then you can
understand how the system is working and
you can use that to then make some of
your decisions and one of the ideas
you're gonna come recurrently in the
talk is that if you have such a system
you can you can use it to predict but
sometimes the predictions may or may not
be perfect so what you can do is then is
can complement the predictions with some
small experiments to try to calibrate
those predictions and then using the
combination of the modeling and that the
outcome or the output coming from this
assignment and a limited number of
experiments then you can learn what to
do without a lot of you know online work
that is very expensive at time consume
okay so one of the goals of the talk
today is also to present you with some
of the different matching products that
we have at Facebook because some of them
are slightly different there are
different things that we can do with
them to try to improve their design and
try to improve their products some of
them are going to be speaking about now
are in the area of social good so one
that we have a talk yesterday maybe some
of you were here yesterday is around
blood donations so what this product
does is to try to match people that are
willing to donate blood to blood banks
hospitals or other people that need
blood and what we do there is two people
that who resistor as donors we provide
recommendations about places they can go
to donate blood so again this is
directly matching problem there are some
particularities that people cannot
donate blood too often so we need to
deal with that but are not that it's
just cutting the the supply-demand the
weights between the two sides estimating
those weights and then solving this type
of matching or ranking or recommendation
systems you can view this problem from
all the terms taxes I mention at the
beginning so that's one example another
one is on fund fund raisers so when you
do charitable donations there is a
feature by which you can match what
somebody donates to an NGO so somebody
can say hey I have this money so for
whoever donates to an NGO that I mean
Tracy that I'm gonna match the funds so
one of the questions here is what are
the what are good ways to incentivize
more people to donate so again is in
this case what your matching is your
dollars that you're putting there as
contributions to donations that a person
makes to an NGO so what's the best way
to match those dollars to
other people to try to incentivize more
people to own it and another product
that exists that Facebook is this one in
which we recommend mentors to mentees so
these this is part of groups so Facebook
there are groups and where people can
enroll to talk about a given topic
usually so in some of these groups you
can designate us be part of this product
the mentorship product and what the what
this does is that people can enroll as a
mentor or as a mentee and what the
product does is to them match mentors to
mentees so they can have a conversation
and learn more about something so I've
used this as an example I have a
daughter who's gonna be who's gonna be
going to college next year I have no
idea about how to apply to colleges in
the u.s. because I haven't been to
college in the u.s. so enrolling one of
them and they gave me some feedback
about like what the what are things I
can do to try to cater to colleges that
are aligned to her interests so this is
proved useful to me and from a product
perspective the questions was the best
way to match mentors mentees and again
it's like a standard matching problem
and this is a new product this is not
part of social good but it's a product
the launch a couple of weeks ago
Facebook dating so in this product now
people can create a new profile which is
not mapped to the actual Facebook
profile of people this is Facebook and
Instagram and what the product does is
to then match people that may be your
partner people you may date yeah so so
this is a this is no product and
launched in the u.s. recently it's been
active in twenty other countries for
some time I think the last year or so
yeah we'll see some looking forward to
see how these goes in the US so one of
the features of this product is this
secret crush in which you can list some
people that are your people that you
secretly love and then if area does that
if there is a match then we may mention
that hey so though I mean this pair leg
is a pair of secret lovers so you may
want to talk to that person so I think a
nice question from our back for
our background is how to make that that
feature incentive compatible so it
cannot be gained something that's
engineering questions so I think the way
that has been implemented there is some
friction and people cannot change that
too much we cannot explore too much I
think that's an interesting question
about how to how to come up with good
solution for that issue one thing I want
to focus on in particular is on these
job applications so another thing that
happen at Facebook is that people have
been using the platform to look for jobs
and to offer jobs they happen
organically and for a long time so there
were groups that existed about finding
jobs in given geographical areas or
forgiving topics or type of jobs so at
some point Facebook realize that and
decided to create a product around this
so instead of night writing tags in a
group about hey so I'm looking for a job
of these characteristics so what the
product does is you can input the type
of job that that that you're offering so
to try to solicit applications and then
for the seeker side you can rank and
list some of the jobs that are available
in your area for some characteristics so
you can look for full-time jobs per
thousand jobs in a given area in a given
type of category and then you'll see a
list of jobs that are offered so you can
apply to it and then you know your match
to the to the to a company and maybe
you're gonna be interviewed if you one
thing we note so that that's again is a
matching problem right so so we have
many job seekers we have many jobs we
need to match one to the other and we
commend to job seekers what jobs they
may be interested at so they can apply
one thing we notice that we will start
running this product is that there was
some congestion effects so basically I'd
done some jobs got many applications and
some other jobs got fewer applications
so question here is how to balance the
market and that goes into what is
credible beginning which is we won the
matching to be somewhat fair we want
people to not regret the type of
recommendations we're giving them so you
know so Eric has access to all the jobs
here in theory have access to all the
jobs because you can scroll forever and
see all of them but what we put on top
is important
how we can balance that market so most
people have access to most jobs that are
relevant to them so that's why we want a
fair allocation when we solve this type
of matching markets so as we think about
these so if you look at this ranking and
you saw really for some type of value
model and then you start from top to the
bottom you can do some centralized
optimal matching to do that and that you
know you may need to have hope try to
add all these fairness constraints to
make sense of being able to balance the
market or you can take it step further
and then look at these from some of
these marketplace perspectives to try to
have these automatically yes yeah
totally I mean that's the main issue so
the question is is there learning mode
so yes indeed so we don't know the
intrinsic quality for every job that
gets posted so we can try to learn
through how people interact with these
jobs so if many people click on the job
if any people apply for the job which
are things we know because people click
on these buttons but you also have the
risk of you know getting the richer the
rich get richer effect right so you see
if by some random coincidence too many
people applied to this job then we think
is really good and this is gonna be more
likely to be shown in the feed in the
job feed of more people so I guess what
we like is we'll have we'd like to have
enough exploration so all jobs are given
some chance so so people can learn the
true quality and then from there we can
continue ranking so how to do this
properly is the key to this question and
okay so all these examples what do they
have in common they're all matching
markets so we have in this case jobs and
seekers we have the evaluations and then
the hardest thing here is to learn the
wave that will go into these links which
is the learning that we were just
talking about but if you can do that so
the question is how to learn properly
how to expose more jobs to more seekers
so we can learn the true qualities in a
good way and what are the right machine
learning models that we can do there and
after we've done that was the right way
to match one side to the other Bank and
should indeed is probably well known to
most people so one of the done
of these comparable urea type of Mali's
that you can solve this as a convex
optimization problems so you can write
like a centrally annotation problems
fall for it this may be easier or harder
as a convex optimization problem but if
you can solve this one then you have an
output for this so you can think of
these market equilibriums as any other
centralized matching problem that you
can solve instead of using out an LP or
an integer program a linear program use
this convex program to solve but one of
the issues that both linear program
integer program or convex program they
they don't scale that much so when you
have millions or billions of the items
inside maybe you can even like fit in
memory or all these variables so to be
able to do some iterative algorithm to
be able to solve that so one of the
questions we had is how we can do this
in practice before we go to solution
like and this I mention earlier like
this community equilibrium gives you
like many nice properties are one regret
and B being parrot optimal solving Nash
welfare and one so there is a new paper
that some of my co-authors have is that
you can even add constraints of the kind
that you cannot sign at most one of your
side to these without breaking some
restructure about the convex prone I
told yoga yes what all revenue yeah so
revenues one of the metrics one I told
you earlier other trade-offs one is
welfare the other would be revenue
depending on the type of product so if
you look at jobs there is no revenue so
we're all trying to make the best
assignment this is minoo monetized and
if you look at ads there is revenue and
then there are trade-off between revenue
on welfare and through this you may
wanna look at that those trade-off and
select the operating point that makes
sense to you
well it depends on the model you select
if you are using real money or non fake
money depending on that you can you can
be paid and if you are paid you can look
at your revenue if it's fake money you
are looking to maximize welfare with the
some of the utilities of all the users
so depending on the on which of these
models you are looking at you may
incorporate that or not depending on
what you need and so let me not mention
a little about how to solve this in
practice when the market is large so we
have the product which is this market
that we've been talking about then
becomes practice and matching market
right so this is the real product this
is the abstraction this is my matching
market the two sides with the values
that we mentioned earlier but that's the
one I mention maybe is too large for us
to solve so what we came up with is this
idea of taking a compact representation
of the market and I have a slide later
so the whole idea is that from to come
from the abstracted market to the
compact market what you do is you may
take a look run low-rank approximation
of the evaluation matrix or you can do
clustering between like the two sides of
the market and then take a smaller
market on the two sides and then compute
the edges the edges and the weights of
the edges in a way that is compatible
with what you had initially now we have
a compact market this is small enough so
you can go ahead and solve it so when
you solve the company will Ihram now you
have an assignment and you have prices
for the goods in the item but this is no
good because this is really far away
from the product the original product so
what you do is you can lift it to the
original abstraction here and there are
different ways you can do that but if
every one of these nodes was
representing a group of the nodes when
you did clustering initially you can
project up and then you can assign you
can try to take this representative
assignment and then assign it to the
abstraction you had initially and same
with the prices so you have prices for
the goods you need to come up with
prices for the this bigger market that
is the represents reality and now now
you have a solution to
or upfront model but this is like real
size of millions or billions of items
and now you can use these to try to make
some get some insights or make some
decisions for a product so this is
validation earlier so the two ideas that
you can apply concurrently are
clustering and using low rank up
approximations so if you cluster you can
cluster both the goods and they and
buyers each of them will have some
features that will describe the goods
and the buyers when you do like k-means
or any other clustering algorithm you
can get the representative for the
features that describe the buyer or the
good and then this is what gives you the
the smaller compact market you can find
the weights by taking for example the
inner product between the two sides on
the market that will give you their
weights and that will give you a smaller
matrix that you can use to solve this
problem some of the properties you can
get from there is that now if you
project up to the original space of the
of the big market now you have a new
matrix these new matrix will represent
the the clustering or may represent the
low-rank approximation of the original
matrix so one thing I'm prove is that
like some of the metrics that we wanted
like mu regret a welfare etcetera are
bounded by the distance between the
original matrix and the and the compact
matrix and you can prove this so see in
a way what I'm saying is that as you
compact you're not losing too much so it
won't be exactly yeah exactly and be
free but will be approximately be free
so that so that's kind of fine the
second property is that as you project
up you're not losing too much either so
so you can go back to the original and
solution to this to the equilibrium for
the original abstraction and that's not
too bad compared to you know what you
would have done if you had solve the
original market yes in this case yeah is
they the utility of her any good for any
buyer yes exactly yes but but the prices
are the outcome of these nor the input
right but yeah
question probabilistic quantity right so
because it can be a preference of jobs
to a seeker so in that world when you
cluster the probabilistic view is going
trade either you can interpret the same
way as interpret the original one so the
usual interpretation of these matrices
that that's the utility you'll get if
you were to assign you to that job right
in that sense is deterministic is no
probably stick right so so so this is
the basic definition of comedy lira is
deterministic so I take the abstraction
now this is not the exact the exact
utility is going to be a representation
of the until you get if you take one the
representative of that cluster of jobs
because you don't have the real one in
that in that one yes I think that's an
our idea of what you can do so we try
this one I'm not saying that other ideas
cannot be tried part of me part of the
reason of representing this is to like
elicit others to be looking at these
things so yeah there there are many
other ways in which wacom one can
project into a more compact
representation so this one
yeah seem to work and we're happy with
it but I'm not saying that others don't
work yes the utility will be they you
know that the edges the weights of the
edges in the in a matching problem and
the you have to apply some machine
learning or some other way to learn
those weights in the options also if you
present in the option I have to bid for
different people how much I'm willing to
and we need to pay so in terms of
information requirement is not different
from what you would get in an option
exactly
the beauty
so if you try these ideas in practice so
within a simulation study in which we
took a matrix and we try these four
different ways different abstraction
levels so we can we condense the market
in the two ways I mentioned by taking
class rings
and by taking low ranks and the question
is in practice how far are we depending
how much we compact the market or how
much how much abstraction we take this
is a busy slide are many graphs but say
take any of them for example MB what
this says is depending how much what
percentage you take the abstraction so
one would be hundred percent we take
everything to zero it means that you
compact it a lot meaning that for every
cluster it is very large so you take
only a few representatives and the color
of represent to what rank in the matrix
you are taking so this is saying like as
you compact how much you lose in terms
of the maximum MB you may have and so as
you see the curves don't decrease to to
much it means that you're not losing too
much by taking these compact
representations so that's kind of what I
want to transmit with these days an
approach that seems to worrying practice
that we can compute the equilibria make
sense and from there
you form some of the operations at least
earlier Tannen to15 right what's the
structure of the market which this
approach will do really bad and I didn't
try to take a worst-case approach to
this so we have the theoretical bounds
that tell us how buddy can do you know
in the worst case when we try this with
actual instances coming from real
markets or real matching problems it
seem to be doing things related to this
but I haven't tried to compute the worst
case that will match the you know the
worst gets bounced that we have here
okay so given I hope I have another 10
minutes I want to focus the second part
of the talking also telling you about
like some of the weights that happen in
practice how do we compute them how do
you make sure that these models make
some sense in practice so we can inform
the operation in the right way so in
this second part I'll talk a little
Bayesian optimization some of the mix
between the decentralized solutions we
have been talking about so far with what
happens in practice so other keywords or
other interesting things around this is
how to how to deal with exploration and
exploitation and how to work with
trade-off between matrix matrices and
the type of thing is happy I will be
talking about our basic had been open
source in these two packages that are
available online so ax and both holes
and are there on the web so if any of
these looks interesting to you can go to
those web pages there are many tutorials
there are many ways in which you can
like learn more about these and try this
out if that's useful to you okay so
going back to these weights how do we
learn the weight how do you make sure
the model makes sense in practice so
it's a big world there are many many
people live in different places
different conditions it's really hard to
learn things properly when when you're
expose your things to many different
people in the world so what people have
been doing traditionally has been to run
experiments so you have a theory that
something may work maybe there are a few
parameters you don't know how much they
are what you can do is you can run a few
experiments you try your parameter at
certain values then you measure like the
outcome of these maybe you measure the
engagement you may measure the welfare
or the revenue or how many videos or
words or how many posts are read
whatever it is that you care about you
measure that then you try again with no
combination of parameters you measure
all those metrics again and you keep
doing that until you are happy with
something that seem to work like a
concrete example of the feed so the way
feed work is that if a user comes into
the platform there are a number of items
that can be shown to that person
typically somebody in product decided
that a way to run key through some value
model that has many turn
the terms may have to do with how likely
you are to click on that item how many
friends the the person you're talking
the the person who wrote the post has
was the strength between you and that
person in terms of the tie was the
probability that that post is Pam etc
right so they made many other terms here
like how to wait between those terms
so typically engineer doesn't know so
what they do is they add a constant in
front of each maybe you have an exponent
or maybe divider something but you don't
know what we don't know how much these
numbers are so we need to learn those
numbers to make sense of that value if
we have these values then rendering a
finishes for every possible post we
compute that we sort from top to bottom
and that's your field but the question
is how to learn these numbers so the
field makes sense in practice so this is
how people as I said have been running
experiments for these some some people
decide to run to right sorry a simulator
so they can interact with this faster so
they wrote the simulator the problem is
the simulator when he was contrasted
some experimentation
it was super bias so then if it's bias
is not easy to make decisions something
else bias because then the decisions are
gonna be wrong the question is what to
do and this is kind of the end of the
story this is a some text taken from a
post by an Instagram ranking engineer
that says that we've seen significant
improvements over the years by turning
this value model we typically use
Gaussian processes and Bayesian
optimization to do it and then here you
can plot the surface of for example for
two of the parameters there are more but
is only two this is like some metric how
how the shape looks like and you like to
optimize that to take the maximum the
maximum point there so question is how
to learn that surface efficiently yes
they are doing better than what you can
run experiment so say you change these
you move like these number by two right
so you run into experiment 2 so you
select a one percent of the users you
expose them to a new feed you measure
how well they have well the platform
does in that experiment and then you
compute the treatment effects for that
feed so you know it's better than
production just think you know baked
well likely space is like just this
example of something that looked really
good within some of the metrics the
Facebook try to get rid of it because
they have other things cool that's a
great point but then so that point is
about whether you're using the right
metric not whether you're optimizing
that metric so you're totally so so
that's it that's a discussion happens
all the time so for example you may want
to increase the number of users you have
in the platform but if the users include
include the paid users then you're
bringing more fake users to platform
which is something you don't like
so the right metric was the number of
real users not the number of users total
so coming up with the right metric is a
problem in itself and it's very
important and interesting
so yeah thank you so what we need to do
is we need to find this edge weight in
properly and that's not easy to do that
for many different problems we need to
tune parameters or maybe through the
value model maybe through another
machine learning model maybe you are
running different regressions logistic
regressions or different kind of
regressions to know what the edges are
there or not maybe you are reusing the
learning so whether it is that we are
doing we may need some parameters so
questions what do we do so one thing
that is generally case is that the
outcomes are often smooth in these
parameters so if we change like one of
these parameters a little things don't
change that much so if you can take this
move view then what you can do is you
can try to keep learning by you know
sampling from the parameter space
learning through an experiment what's
going to happen and then something
sample again so that's the whole idea is
to have these iterations so we take a
parameter we take a vector of parameters
we value it with experiments we fit a
model and that will give us new
candidates to try new parameters so
traditionally what people have done is
they look at this grid search so you try
like or parallel combinations in some
space but I promise that that doesn't
scale the if you have too many brothers
we cannot take all grid points in many
stay in a big space because that means
that you have to run too many
experiments and you have enough time or
users to be able to let so that that
idea doesn't really work in practice so
the idea that does work in practice is
based on optimization which has been
used successfully by many people in the
company in many other companies this is
very common these days so what you do is
then you have up to some point you've
run a few experiments so you have some
confidence interval around the metrics
for different parameter points that you
already tried this cannot be seen but
here here we have a continuous band that
is hard to see in the slides and the
confidence band like may be very narrow
in the cases where you run the
experiment and very really wide like
here in the in the places where we
haven't run any experiments so you don't
know really so what you're trying to
manage
some exploration versus exploitation so
what can you do so at this stage you can
say look this looks very close to
optimal and I cover a narrow confidence
interval here so maybe I wanna exploit
that and keep doing the this type of
parameter or you can say look here I
have an estimate is high and the
confident room is really wide so maybe
it's even higher than what I have there
so Mario and I keep running experiments
in this region so what you can do then
is you can compute the expected
improvement if you were to run the next
experiment in a different parameter so
this is the what's what I'm plotting
here so what this gives you is then what
is the next candidate that you should
run so now the next country is this one
it means that what I should do next to
solve this exploration exploitation
trade-off is to run a new experiment at
this point and then you keep doing that
so this has been used a lot so as I said
we don't have it's hard to run some an
experiment so the way this works in
practice if you want to make this more
efficient is to complement this
experimentation platform with some other
way to run either simulate or solve
models in practice that doesn't involve
experimentation so what we do is we do
it two things together we draw from the
experiments and from the simulation and
we try to put all that data together fit
a model and then continue exploring and
generating new candidate exactly yeah so
from the if you know something is wrong
you can use matrix completion other
things like that to try to guess some of
these things so the more you know them
the more structure we can impose to
these models and the faster you can
learn so the whole point then is to put
everything together so we have the
simulations you have some of the online
experimentation you simulation is
cheaper so you can run many of those you
run a few of the expert experiments that
are more expensive you create a model
together with all that and that will
give you a new candidate that you keep
iterating and that's just a few graph in
which you can see how the simulators are
biased so if everything was perfect we'd
get points on this line but you don't
but if you complement this with some of
these online experimentation what you
get is that things are get unbiased and
you get the right operating point for
different parameters another you know
this now because the you know your
process you can you can simulate offline
in a right way
now you can optimize for that and take
the maximum which is what you wanted so
that's an example when you optimize feed
using Bayesian optimization in each of
these batches you have more of the
experiments and more of the simulations
and you can see how the metrics is gonna
come out close to the optimum and okay
so so to conclude so this is type of the
kind of the how you trade with these
both orge is this package I mention
earlier which is the based optimization
package that will allow you to optimize
under uncertainty whether you know the
right structure of a function so you
make some assumptions you need to learn
the shape of the functions and through
patient you session you can keep
generating new new and parameter
configuration through ax which is the
other package we open source is the one
that will run the whole process you will
do the bookkeeping of taking all these
parameter combinations generating more
simulations and doing the whole thing so
between the two basically what you can
try to optimize your matrix and and
achieve these goals that we thought that
we talked about all right so to recap we
I try to give you like a
an overview of different things we do to
try to improve some of the products
using techniques coming from matching
markets optimization and the type of
work that collected in this room we we
deal with and the whole idea is that
through being able to improve the scale
and the accuracy of these models we can
inform both the strategy of the products
and the operations of product in the
right way to go back to you know the
engineers project product managers
technical product project managers etc
and try to help them guide the decisions
that they do in the projects thank you
very much
[Applause]
yeah there are papers and yeah the
papers are there like I can yeah I can
try to post them now I'll talk to
organizers to see what's the best way I
would feel free to ping me I'll give you
the talk was recorded oh yeah see they
do my charger
[Music]